good morning Hank it's Monday August 2nd
Willie I'm trying to film along good
morning Hank it's Monday August 2nd 2010
unless you live in Australia in which
case it is Tuesday August 3rd 2010 which
means that at least in Australia it is
nerdfighter Esther 16th birthday today
aka Esther day so when I met Esther in
Boston I promised her that on her
birthday in perpetuity we would make
videos about whatever she wanted us to
make videos about and yesterday she got
back to me with what she wants yesterday
to be all about and she said she wants
it to be about family and love isn't it
enough just to show you that I love you
without having to talk about it I'm a
boy I don't like to talk about it but
it's Esther day so we're gonna talk
about family and love okay so there's
this restaurant near my house called
hotcakes Emporium pancake house
restaurant it's a very long name
restaurant let's just shorten it to
heifer right so on the menu whatever
they have a side dish called freedom
fries which look and taste like french
fries but they're not french fries
because they're freedom fries not like
you may remember that in 2003 some
members of the US Congress got mad at
France because France did not believe
there was a link between Iraq and
al-qaeda they got so mad at friends that
in the Congressional cafeteria they
renamed french fries freedom fries and
french toast
freedom toast I'm not entirely sure why
France would even want to be associated
with french fries which first of all are
not French they're Belgian and second of
all they're very bad for you it's like
if there was an independent nation
called the heroin and we got mad at it
and we are like we're renaming heroin
freedom the nation of heroin would
probably be like thank you but anyway
Hague apparently Heffer is still mad at
France so they still call french fries
freedom fries which leads me to an
interesting question is a freedom fry a
french fry tank there's a famous moment
in the play Romeo and Juliet where
Juliet says that which we call a rose by
any other name would smell as sweet
Juliet's saying that what we call
something doesn't matter the only thing
that matters is the thing itself as it
really is but spoiler alert it's worth
noting that that worldview does not
actually spell success for Romeo and
Juliet I would argue Hank that there's
ample evidence that the words we use to
describe the things we feel Matt that in
fact french fries and freedom fries are
not the same thing a French fries a
delicious albeit carcinogenic food and a
freedom fry is a really stupid political
statement made more stupid by the fact
that all American political parties now
acknowledge that we were wrong and the
French were right so maybe we should
just quietly go back to calling them
french fries let me give you another
hypothetical example Hank say you love
your brother but you don't actually want
to say you love him because there's just
a lot of emotion and stuff built up over
the last 30 years so hypothetically
maybe you just say you like him and then
try to show him you love him
you know by like having thousands of
people plant tens of thousands of trees
for his birthday or something I don't
know what the thing is that is not
actually the same thing as telling your
brother you love him which i think is
what Esther wants me to do and maybe
what Esther wants all of us to do so
maybe yesterday is the day where we
think who do I love who I have trouble
saying I love you too not some romantic
interest that's just using Esther day as
an excuse to tell someone you love them
that you already want to tell them no I
mean family or platonic friends which
for me is even harder than family
Hank I love you and your punishment is
that you have to do a makeup tutorial
you know in this style of YouTube makeup
tutorials deadline September 1st
so nerdfighters join with Esther and me
and tell someone you love that you love
them today and if you're feeling
exhibitionistic let us know who it's
hard to say I love you too in comments
happy birthday Esther Hank I'll see you
on Wednesday